hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website calm today are going to be
continuing our series on bobby fischer
for the upcoming graphic novel bobby
fischer the knight who killed the kings
before we get into it i've had a lot of
requests to update people on how the
graphic novel is doing it's coming along
there's a few more chapters out so i
definitely want to let you guys know
about that we do have a link in the
description below so definitely make
sure you click on that it's turning out
extremely well i think you guys are
really really gonna like it i love to
hear more feedback about it
i do kind of want to preview chapter 2
and 3 are both out again all you have to
do is click on the expand will go ahead
and kind of look at it chapter 2 this is
kind of going to be what the video is
about today this is from Petrosian who's
actually going to go on to to win this
particular tournament but if we kind of
look at it you know there's a lot of
different views that you can look at if
you kind of want to do it more of a
comic style you can kind of flip the
pages like this you can always zoom and
if you want to the illustrations are
very very good chapter 2 again is about
the 1962 candidates tournament in couric
au which is our video about if you want
to kind of go back chapter 3 it kind of
shows a very interesting conversation
about chess so if you really enjoy chess
i think you're really going to enjoy
this so again check it out again the
link is below you guys really really
going to enjoy it again bobby fischer
the knight who killed the king's fan
fantastic work and let's go ahead and
jump into the video today's game comes
to us from the 1962 candidates
tournament taking place in kerr account
the game is between Bobby Fischer and
Mikhail Atala now if you're not too
familiar with the candidates tournament
basically you have the World
Championship with the current reigning
world champion and who's he play none
other than the winner of the candidates
tournament so very prestigious
tournament top players from around the
world basically try to come win this
tournament so they can have a shot at
being the world champion now in this
particular game Bobby Fischer is going
to be playing the white pieces mikhail
tall one of the top players in the world
in 1962 is going to be playing the black
pieces now bobby fischer at this time is
18 years
old and tall is going to be 26 years old
at this time so we'll go ahead and get
into it Bobby Fischer starts the game
with pawn to d4 very very normal for
Bobby Fischer while a lot of people back
in this time anything currently start
out with d4 Bobby Fischer being the
aggressive player starts out with pawn
to e4 tall is going to respond with the
Sicilian defense very very sharp of
defense against the pawn to e4 move from
Bobby Fischer White's not going to play
Knight to f3 trying to control the
center of the board these dark scores in
particular with his knight and tall is
going to respond doing the same thing
Knight to c6 again developing towards
the center trying to control the stern
of the board with his minded pieces and
support these pawns early on into the
game Bobby Fischer is going to continue
push forward with his pawn here and
after the exchange now tall decides to
play pawn to e5 again threatening and
putting a more pressure on this dark
square here on d4 now Bobby Fischer does
have two different options he could
always bring his knight back to b3 we
can always play the aggressive move
which he does Knight to b5
now from here tall just going to play
pawn to a6 really wants to kick this
night off right here and the Knights now
come to d6 it is again checking this
King obviously it's an early check it's
going to be dealt with very very quickly
but after the exchange Bobby Fischer is
now going to have the doubled Bishop so
early on to the game you can see this is
going to be very very good for Bobby
Fischer but black is able to respond
very very well now he does want to make
sure that he gets this Queen kind of
back he doesn't really want to deal with
this Queen all up in his business right
here so he decides to bring his Queen
out to f6 again threatening this Queen
right here there's not a lot that this
Queen can do doesn't really have a lot
of minor support so he's just going to
kick his queen back here to d1 now black
is going to bring his queen over to g6
really wasn't doing anything here on f6
so he's going to try to make it as
active as possible he really wants to
make sure that Bobby Fischer doesn't get
a lead as far as a development lead or a
spatial advantage right now black is
starting to have a small lead as far as
spatial and Development you can see
Bobby Fischer has all of these pieces
back on his first row right here
so he's going to try to continue and be
aggressive on the black side so tall
does play Queen to f6
excuse me g6 threatening this pawn here
on e4
Bobby Fischer decides to respond with
Knight to b3 again not only is it a
development move towards the start of
the board but it's also controlling and
defending this pawn here on e4 again as
we talked about over and over in these
videos again minor pieces are really
meant in the early part of the game
trying to control the center of the
board put pressure on your opponent but
also to protect pawns as the pawns
really lay that foundation for where
you're going to be controlling which is
early on the center of the board now
later on once that goes into the middle
game towards the endgame the minor
pieces are going to be supporting and
attacking the major pieces playing a
more pivotal role but early on that
they're really going to be laying the
foundation for your other pieces so do
just keep that in mind from here tall is
going to play Knight to e7 he wants to
make sure that he gets this knight
involved into the game he could have
brought it to f6 if he wanted to he
decides to bring it here to e7 now the
only time you don't want to bring your
knight to e7 is if you still have your
Bishop here on f8 you don't want to
block that Bishop off but Beeson because
that Bishop from f8 has already come out
into the game it doesn't really matter
now if the knight comes to e7 also it's
now defending this night here on c6 so
these Knights are really playing off of
each other also it does allow this
knight to control both the d5 and the f5
squared which are very pivotal as White
is trying to control those with his pawn
here on e4
now White's not going to bring his pawn
up to h4 basically signifying that he's
not going to be castling on the King
side this is as you can see really
really weakening the King side but you
know he really wants to make sure that
he can get his bishop involved into the
game he does have this semi open D foul
so he wants to kind of keep that open
for his Queen right here it's kind of a
passive move right here to bring his
Bishop to e3
so obviously f4 is not going to be much
of a help so if he does decide to bring
his bishop over here to g5 he needs to
make sure he does have a pawn
on age 4 to protect that so later on he
could be looking to castle on the
queenside now black decides to bring his
pawn to h5 signifying that he's probably
not going to be castling on the kingside
as well but again really trying to make
sure that you know there's no counter
play
he's also later setting up an outpost
here on g4 if he wants to so just a few
things to keep in mind the bishop is now
going to come to g5 as we talked about
obviously pawns are always going to be
forming outposts so these outposts could
be for a major piece or in this
particular case it could be for a minor
piece like this Bishop here on g5 black
now sides decides he doesn't really
matter if this knight comes off the
board here on a7 it wasn't doing a whole
heck of lot so he decides to start
pushing forward again he does have a
slight lead in development so he's going
to try to pressure the center of the
board now I actually would have liked
Bobby Fischer to taking this pawn here
on d5 I thought that was a much better
move than what he actually played he
decided to take with his Bishop here on
e7 you know obviously black if you
wanted to could take this bishop back
right here I don't really understand why
Bobby Fischer decided to give up his
Bishop pair here but you know it is what
it is
tal decides instead of taking he just
decides to push forward with his pawn
here on d4 again putting pressure on
this knight on c3 which is defending
this pawn here on e5 now any time you're
playing again this Queen is putting a
lot of pressure on the e4 square now
this knight here is the defender so one
big thing you always see in chess is you
want to remove the defender so the
defender of this pawn here is right here
so blacks going to try to remove that
defender here from c3 now Bobby Fischer
is already taking this piece on e7 he no
longer decides he wants to get rid of
the bishop here so he brings his bishop
back to g5 and then black decides he
wants to capture now the problem with
White's position right here is he now
has doubled pawns and tall can now come
in and take this pawn here on e4 again
once that defender was removed then the
Queen can come in here to e4 now if you
look at this black has a
much much better position as you can see
as far as the pawns
that the pawns are saying the rest of
materials the same but black just has a
much more aggressive and established
position than White has why it's kind of
all over the place he does have these
doubled pawns here so you know again a
few moves ago while he did try to just
exchange his pieces here on e7 probably
would have been a little bit better if
he decided to just keep this here and
then take here on d5 but it is what it
is Bobby Fischer now has to you know
respond to this Queen here on e4 so he
brings his Bishop to e2 blockiness again
trying to develop his pieces tall is now
going to play pawn to f6 solidifying his
pawn chain and also kicking this bishop
off here on g5 so this Bishop Rhian g5
you know while it did some good it's
really not going to do much anymore it
is forced to retreat back here to e3 now
Black has one more piece that he needs
to get involved into the game to
complete his development and that is
bringing his LightSquared Bishop
involved into the game again as we've
talked about in many of the other videos
you want to develop all of your pieces
than if you can you want to connect your
rooks on the back rank you want to
centralize those rooks you want to get
them on semi open or open files and they
even want to start to formulate a game
plan going into the middle and the late
game so that's exactly what black is
trying to do here it brings his Bishop
over to g4 very similar to what white
did he does have this pawn here on h5
making a nice little outpost here on g4
White's going to respond bringing his
Queen to d3 he wants to see if he can
exchange these Queens off the board and
then make sure he doesn't have these
doubled pawns right here tall decides to
go ahead and exchange and so White has
two different options he could take with
his Bishop here or he could take with
this pawn obviously the pawns going to
be much better you capture towards the
center of the board and he gets rid of
those double pawns right here so very
very good for white right here now black
decides to go ahead and capture this
bishop here on e2 white no longer has
the bishop pair which is a very very
good thing for tall since Bobby Fischer
is really really well-known for doing
terrible things to their opponents with
with a double Bishop pair so the White
King is now going to recapture on e2 now
Bobby Fischer can no longer castle but
it doesn't really matter once the
Queen's come off the board and most of
the other minor and major pieces come
off the board then the King actually
needs to start getting involved into the
game he's a centralized himself he
becomes a huge asset as far as attacking
his opponent so Bobby Fischer has
completed his development
he's also connected his rooks on the
back ranked Black has to do the same
thing so he's going to castle on the
Queen side again the black King has not
moved yet so he decides to do the same
thing he's Castle so not only is he
connected his rooks on the back ring but
he's also centralized his rook here on
d8 so again as we talked about once you
connect those rooks then you want to
centralize them if you can get them on a
semi-open or an open file this rook
right here on d8 is on a semi-open file
which is going to be very very good for
black white now responds with Knight
excuse me rook to d1 again centralizing
the same thing black is going to bring
his knight over to e7 wants to put it in
a much better place eventually you know
he could if he wanted to bring it here
to f5 he could bring it over here to g6
threatening this pawn here on h4 if this
rook here on h1 ever moved or we could
bring it down to d5 threatening this
pawn here on c3 now White's going to
bring his pawn up to d4 again
threatening the center of the board
right here and the Knights now going to
come down to d5 now he is threatening
this pawn here on c3 which would fork
both the King here and the rook here on
d1 so why it's going to have to respond
you can't really leave your your pieces
hanging so he decides to bring his rook
over to c1 makes sense the rooks is now
going to come over to e8 again blacks
just kind of centralizing everything not
only is he centralizing it but you
definitely want to have your rooks and
your queens or other major pieces on the
same file as your opponent's king things
just tend to go better if you're on the
same file as your opponent's king that's
exactly what White's doing as well even
though more than likely he's kind of
here to protect this pawn here on C
three now White's gonna bring his rook
over to d1 centralizing it also trying
to put a little bit more pressure and
defense on this pawn on d4 and now black
decides to bring this pawn to f5 now I
don't know this is the best move in here
it does open up the door for the bishop
to come back to g5 but any case like
this now has to move his rook since it's
being attacked so it just kind of brings
it forward one move to d7 right here and
then Bobby Fischer decides to capture
right here on e5 kind of open things up
again you know allowing his King to be
attacked once this rook comes in but he
decides you know is to bring his King
over to f3 and he decides this is going
to be very very safe for him he's really
only worried about this knight on d5
it's going to actually be very very easy
for him to defend against these rooks
it's going to be really hard for them to
come and put a lot of pressure they
can't really control since these pawns
are here on f5 blockading these long you
know link the F files so instead it's
going to be very hard to match these up
on like the you know the third rank or
the fourth rank so he decided it's going
to be well okay it's kind of exchange
those pawns off and allow this rook to
come here to e5 now blacks going to
bring his rook down to e4 making sure
that this King doesn't move anywhere
again he does have this outpost because
of the pawn here on f5 and now the rooks
going to come to d3 wants to make sure
no funny business happens this rook
obviously can come over to the e-file as
well and that's what we want to make
sure does not happen for Bobby Fischer
and now the rooks is going to come over
to see for this is putting a lot of
pressure on this pawn on c3 more
pressure than white can really deal with
so instead he decides to put all this
pressure on the d1 putting a lot of
pressure on this d1 file and black
decides to go ahead and gobble this up
now White's just going to go ahead and
respond and take this back and after the
rook recaptures then Bobby Fischer's
going to bring his rook over to see one
again pinning this knight down to the
King here on c8 now if we can look at
this though black does have the small
advantage he is up one pawn in material
and he's kind of pinned down this Knight
this night's uh you know dot not doing a
whole lot but again black ease up of
material so does have a small advantage
but does need to be careful because his
pieces you know right now we're kind of
tied up at the moment
black is now going to bring his rook
over to c7 again his night is pinned
down it really doesn't have another move
he wants to make sure that his night is
being protected right here and so Bobby
Fischer decides to bring his Bishop over
to F for more of a central square right
here for Bobby Fischer and tall decides
obviously he has to move his rook but he
still wants to be you know where the it
is protecting this Knight here so just
brings his rook up here to c6 now Bobby
Fischer decides to bring his Bishop to
e5 again just centralizing this Bishop
just putting it in a better position
every single time not only is it still
attacking this square on c7 but it's now
attacking this pawn here on g7 it also
now has two attackers on the night here
on c3 now the knight comes back here to
d5 and Bobby Fischer responds with rook
over to d1 now I do think it'd be a
little bit better if Bobby Fischer
decided just to go ahead and take with
his rook here on c6 as you can see here
the pawns just going to come over and
take here on c6 but then the bishop
could come over here to g7 this is going
to be a very very good game for Bobby
Fischer as you can see it's going to be
even in material but Bobby Fischer has
the better minor piece going into the
endgame as you watching in my other
videos you know if there's two sides of
pawns so there's pawns on this side of
the board and this side the board the
bishops going to fare much better
because you can get to both sides of the
board very very quickly if it's just one
side of the moor if they were you know
this pawn was gone this palm was gone
this palm was gone it was pawns only on
the right side the knight actually tends
to do better because he can control more
squares but he doesn't have to move from
one side of the board to the other so in
this particular case I give the nod to
Bobby Fischer with the bishop going into
the endgame but you know he decided not
to do this so instead of bringing his
Bishop excuse me exchanging here on c6
he decided to
just bring his rook over to d1 attacking
this Knight again here on d5 tall no
longer wants to have his knight being
harassed by this rook here on d1 so he
decides to bring it back to f6 and then
Bobby Fischer decides to bring his King
to f4 again later in the game you want
to start getting your King involved into
the game if you can centralize it you
can actually start to put a lot more
pressure on your opponent so definitely
a good move from a Bobby Fischer now the
pawns going to come to g6 this is done
for two reasons one black wants to make
sure that he does solidify all these
pawns obviously this pawn right here on
f5 was being attacked but also he wants
to make sure all of his pawns aren't
opposite colors of Bobby Fischer's
bishop the bishop for Bobby Fischer as
you can see is a dark square bishop so
tall needs to make sure that all this
pawns are on opposite colors so that
Bobby Fischer cannot attack tall's pawn
so you know it's so small little things
that make players a great chess player
but I do want you guys to get better as
you watch these games so you know take
what you learn here and kind of
incorporate in your own game if your
opponent has a dark square Bishop going
into the endgame make sure all of your
pawns are on the opposite color now
Bobby Fischer decides to bring his pawn
to f3 and this is done Willie needs to
make sure that he stops this outpost
obviously the knight here can come to a
nice little outpost on g4 it can also
come to an even better outpost here on
e4 definitely needs to make sure that
that does not happen so pawn to f3 does
exactly that
now the Knights going to come over here
to a d7 attacking this Bishop here on e5
and then the bishop is going to come up
a here to d6 right now Bobby Fischer no
longer wants to exchange the bishop here
on these six so kind of you know block
block hating some of the moves that tall
has now tall is going to bring his rook
it down to c2 attacking this pawn here
on a 2 the next move of rook to c2 I do
think is a little bit of a mistake
actually we'll just like to see tall
bring his knight over to b6 is will kind
of see here a little bit the rook to c2
doesn't do a whole lot of good Bobby
Fischer's just going to respond with
pawn
to g3 you can't really take this pawn
here on a two he's just going to lose
too much material on the kingside it's
just going to be too much trouble for
him so while this does kind of look like
it you know pretty good move obviously
if you you've seen other videos you want
to bring your rook to your opponent's
second or seventh rank depending on
which side your opponent is but in this
particular case there's just not a lot
that he can really do right here so the
rooks going to come over here to e2
Bobby Fischer is going to play King to
g5 now if you're kind of wondering
sitting you know like you know Kevin why
does it why doesn't he just take this
pawn here on a two if he decides to take
it on a two you know he could take that
and then Bobby Fischer if you wanted to
could play you know rook over to c1 and
then we'll just kind of go through the
moves you know he can't really bring you
know his King to b8 it's being attacked
by the bishop so let's say tall decides
to bring his king over to d8 then you
could have Bishop - you know c7 check
and then the king could come over here
to c8 if you want to come back here
the bishop could come back to f4 if you
wanted to the King comes back to d8 and
then the King is going to capture this
pawn here on g6 now there's a some other
variations if you want to kind of go
through that but all in all the king is
going to take this pawn here on g6 if
you wanted to later on he could gobble
up either this pawn here on f5 this pawn
here on h5 after that pretty much he can
mark all of his pawns up the board it's
really really going to be difficult for
black to really do a whole lot as you
can see this pawn here on a6 kind of
blocks him off from bringing his rook up
to a6 putting a lot of pressure on the
King so this rook over here while it did
take this pawn here on a2 now it's kind
of stuck in limbo can't really get
involved into the action and why she was
going to completely dominate the board
so in that particular case since you
can't really take on a - I do think it
was a small mistake even to bring his
rook down into the board over here to
see - in the first place but he kind of
corrects that and instead brings his
rook back up to e6
attacking this bishop here on d6 now the
Bishop's going to come back to f4 9
central square can't really do a whole
lot and so black decides now to bring
his knight up to f8 now while he does
want to make sure that his knights being
attacked this night is just going the
wrong direction you know again it would
have been better if early on he brought
it to b6 right here when you're bringing
all your pieces back you're just kind of
letting your opponent just come at you
and you're kind of playing defensive
which when you have the lead obviously
Black has the lead in material you never
really want your opponent to have all
the momentum what she's kind of giving
white right now White's now going to
play rook to d6 he knows he's pretty
much has the better minor piece so he
has no problem exchanging the rooks off
the board just kind of getting into that
in-game tall decides you know he's going
to start trying to push on the Queen
side he's kind of already you know given
up on the King side so he does have the
slight advantage on the Queen side so
he's going to start to push forward on
this side Bobby Fischer's not going to
bring his king up to h6 eventually he
wants to kind of solidify this a little
bit more he does now have another
opportunity to bring his Bishop to g5 if
he wants to the rooks not going to come
back to e two again now he he's kind of
thinking that you know if he can come
over and take this pawn on a two he can
start to really push forward on the
Queen side he is down as far as an
advantage so he wants to come up with
any strategy he can to try to come back
and either you know tie this game or win
this game white now brings his rook down
to d2 again he has no problem exchanging
the rooks off he just wants to make sure
that this pawn right here kind of stays
because now this pawn becomes a little
bit more important now and that pawns
only more important because this night
on f8 is protecting this pawn on d6
which is we talked about that's what was
going to be the problem before if kind
of you guys were wondering what the
difference is now than it was before
this night here on f6 our excuse me on
it f8 is the big deal
so the works are going to come back to
East 7th all is not ready yet to
exchange pieces you still kind of wants
to have some initiative going so the
bishops now going to come to d6 pinning
this rook down to the the night here on
f8 the rooks are going to come over to
h7 again checking the King here on h6 o
Kings just going to come back here to g5
and then the rooks going to come over
here to f7 he's going to try to you know
have a counter-attack on the King side
it's not really going to go as planned
the rooks are going to come over here to
be to making sure that this bishop or
the scuse me this pawn here on b7
doesn't thrust forward you know either
beast b6 or b5 which is really what
black wants to do trying to get some
sort of attack going can no longer
really do that now the pawn is going to
come forward to f4 kind of a sacrifice
the bishops going to gobble that up and
now the rooks going to come down to f5
and check the King but no worries the
Kings just going to come back to you h6
and it's just going to pretty much dance
back here you know it's going to come g5
and h6 and while this night here on f8
is protecting this pawn on g6 again
early on in the game you want your minor
pieces tied down
protecting your pawns but when you get
into the late game you no longer want
your minor pieces you no longer want
your major pieces their sole duty is
just protecting your pawns that pretty
much you know takes away all of their
initiative so this this knight right
here is not doing a whole lot except
protecting this pawn so I can't really
get involved into the action and attack
this King so this King is free just kind
of move around where he wants to
from here blacks going to play you know
pawn to b5 since he does have this rook
here he can now play the pawn here to b5
and now the Bishop's going to come up to
d6 again always centralizing this Bishop
he can now come to both sides of the
board if you want to making sure that
this pawn doesn't get too out of his
comfort zone and now blacks want to play
pawn to b4 so if you kind of look at
this game you can say okay well both
sides are equal in material but the
problem is white has a huge
in it she does have the much more active
King this King here on c8 it's not doing
anything it's not really threatening
anything it's just kind of sitting out
there what can really attack it at you
know his leisure halls not doing very
much he really doesn't have a strong
initiative while bobby fischer's white
at any given time he can start to gobble
up you know pieces and pawns on the
kingside and one of his minor pieces
here on f8 again is not doing a whole
heck of a lot so you know really Bobby
Fischer has a great opportunity going
into the endgame it's just a matter of
execution which is one thing Bobby
Fischer excels in so from here why
decides to bring his pawn up to g4 he's
again starting that attack on the
kingside the rooks are going to come
down and take here on f3 and Bobby
Fischer plays pawn to g5 this is pretty
much solidifying this pawn here on g6
which is what we talked about you know
really keeping this night here on f8 so
from here the Knights going to come to
esis which is good and bad he does need
to activate his knight but the only
problem with that is he now opens the
door for this King to come on g6 and now
Bobby Fischer has a passed pawn on g5
now the rooks are going to come over to
a d3 attacking this Bishop here on d6
the bishops again just going to
centralize here to e5 the rooks going to
swing back over and the King is going to
come to f5 metal is it protecting this
Bishop here on e5 but it's also allowing
this past pawn to push forward if you
know anything about chess if you have a
passed pawn there's only one thing to do
with it and one thing only is to push
the past pawn so Bobby Fischer's
initiative right now is going to be
passing this up here to the g8 file so
from here the knights going to come back
to f8 and the rooks are going to swing
over to g2 not only is the rook
protecting this pawn here on a2 but you
also want to have your rooks on
semi-open files and you want to put them
behind your pawns as you push those
pawns forward now the rooks are going to
come up to f3 again checking the King
here it's not
going to do a whole lot of good the
bishop's is just going to come back here
to f4 and the king is going to try to
get involved now why it took so long for
the King to get involved who knows but a
little bit too late the pawns now going
to start to push forward now the knights
going to come back here to e6 Bobby
Fischer's just going to continue to push
forward he doesn't really care if the
knight takes because he's going to be
now up a material a rook and a bishop to
a rook which isn't really going to go
very well
so instead Bobby excuse me tal decides
to go ahead and take in the bishop here
and then the King's going to come over
and now the rooks are going to come up
here to f8 so after the pawn takes and
promotes to a queen then after the night
takes Bobby Fischer obviously has a
winning in game here rook is always
going to excel against a knight here
especially when they the Knights not
really involved into the action the rook
can just swing all over the board
especially since there's two sides it's
just going to be too hard for tall to do
too much right here so the Kings going
to come to a d5 centralizing the King
the pawn is going to come to a four
there's not much you can do the rooks
can come up here to g7 checking the King
again this is really forcing this this
King right here in d5 is forcing the
King to move back obviously you can no
longer come to c6 you no longer come to
e6 or d6 so a great little move
obviously if this was on the back rank
it would be checkmate so this is kind of
what it looks like but in this
particular case it forces him to go
backwards so after he comes backward the
King's going to now come to d6 not only
is this a great move centralizing his
King but also really allows this night
to go absolutely nowhere so he comes to
d7 is going to be captured by the the
rook if he comes to e6 he's going to be
captured you can't really come to you
know g6 or h7 he's going to be captured
so black is just kind of sitting there
waiting for Bobby Fischer to win the
game so he decides to bring his upon to
b3 obviously best-case scenario would be
for Bobby Fischer to take and then
recapture you know he would have a
passed pawn right here you know Bobby
Fischer decides you know he doesn't even
care he's just going to play his pawn to
a3 at any given time if
wanted to he could swing his rook rook
over here to b7
put pressure on it if he wanted to but
here aside tall decides to go ahead and
resign even though he is up you know one
pawn Bobby Fischer does have the rook
over the knight advantage so just too
much great game by Bobby Fischer you
know I love doing these games because I
learned so much from both sides you know
both sides had an advantage in the game
black definitely had an advantage he
kind of gave that up while he had the
advantage going into lit into the late
game he started to get a little bit more
passive Bobby Fischer definitely missed
a you know a few opportunities early on
to the game gave that advantage to black
earlier than he probably should have but
in the end Bobby Fischer rose to the
occasion played an extremely extremely
good in game so turned out for the best
so hopefully you guys enjoyed this video
let me know what you think also again
check out the website that we have below
this book is phenomenal guys I think you
will all enjoy it so feel free again to
leave comments about the book it really
means a lot and again going forward we
always want to hear feedback about it
what you guys think what you guys want
want to see so yeah hopefully you
enjoyed and we'll see you guys in the
next video